[Music]
wage growth is not keeping up with
rising inflation forcing many to borrow
credit card debt 13 percent higher than
last year the largest year-over-year
jump in more than 20 years a budget key
to financial security brad zucker says
you can reduce a lot of stress by
knowing how much you have coming in and
how much is going out i just think it's
important that people understand with
rising inflation at the gas pumps in the
grocery checkout lines you must have a
game plan
to combat the worst tax of them all to
people on a fixed income that's
inflation in the rising cost of living
track your expenses nerd wallet has a
free app that does just that once you
see where the money is leaking start
plugging those cracks if you're living
paycheck to paycheck then more than
likely you're going to be giving up on
what we call discretionary expenses that
would be going out to restaurants a
couple nights during the week or buying
clothes and technology and gadgets or a
vacation even cutting back on little
things can add up to make a big
difference uncheck the auto renew
options on any subscriptions you aren't
using regularly think of music streaming
services car wash services gym
memberships online magazines even ebooks
zucker says there is something you can
do right now that will give you more
money in your next paycheck if you filed
your taxes in april and get back a tax
refund you want to change your tax
withholding right now that will
immediately increase your monthly income
and next april your tax refund will
probably be a lot smaller
we do want to hear from you with
inflation affecting prices and products
across the nation how have you changed
your life to adjust head to our twitter
facebook or instagram and drop a comment
and we'll be sharing some of those
responses on air